[Music]
few years ago a wave of vitamin E
deficiency hit many parts of the globe
the deficiency was so severe that it
resulted in several deaths within no
time
what could have been done to crack this
problem scientists soon realized that
the staple food of most of the areas hit
by this disaster was rice
they took efforts to modify rice in such
a way that it produced the necessary
compound in the body when consumed with
this the concept of a Golden Rice
emerged it's a variety of rice that's
capable of bio synthesizing
beta-carotene which is a precursor of
vitamin A when consumed the
beta-carotene is readily converted to
vitamin A in the body does saving
uncountable lives doesn't the sound like
science fiction it definitely does but
this has actually happened let me make
it more interesting imagine there's one
single plant that has potatoes in the
root and tomatoes are the shoot do you
think this is possible
of course it is this variety is called
tomato a plant that bears two edible
parts in the same body and now for the
last one imagine you're in a dark room
and suddenly you find a fluorescently
glowing mice running around do you think
this kind of glowing mice exists yes
they do the concept of fluorescent mice
is no longer fiction because there are
transgenic mice which globe with
fluorescence why are we looking at these
examples we know that computers run on
coats and so do our bodies just like
there are specific codes for running a
computer we have specific codes for
organisms body design and any change in
these codes can give us miraculous
results like the Golden Rice the pomato
plant and
the glowing mice and the study of all
these wonderful concepts is nothing but
genetics we have come across this term
several times
genetics finds applications not only in
modern-day research but even answers
various queries that pop up in our minds
many of us assume that genetics is only
about the characters passed on to the
children from their parents but is it as
simple as that and even if we know or
assume thinks it is important to ask the
question why for instance have you ever
wondered why an apple tree only gives
rise to another apple tree why don't we
get a banana or a mango tree from it why
does a cat give birth to only a kitten
and why do humans give birth to humans
only well you may say that the answer is
nature ok so if a human gives birth to
another human then why are those two not
exactly the same why do we find each
individual unique and what makes the
kids strikingly different from his or
her parents well there are endless
questions that pop up in our minds and
how do we find answers to them that's
where the branch of genetics comes into
play in this lesson and in the upcoming
ones let's get introduced to this branch
and try answering all the questions that
pop up in our minds about the living
world around us to begin with let's
define genetics in simple terms it can
be defined as the branch of biology that
deals with heredity and genetic
variation now you may wonder what do
these two terms mean to begin our
studies on genetics we need to first
understand a few terms in detail let's
begin with understanding what heredity
is here's one happy family now if we
observe this kid he has a few features
like his dad and a few like his mum that
is because he has
got these features from each parent this
passing of treats or characters from one
generation to the other is nothing but
heredity so we can define heredity as
passing of traits from parents to their
offspring now what do we exactly mean by
traits and characters it's simple in
this case the child has black colored
eyes just like his mum
the father however has blue colored eyes
now here we have two different types of
eye colors black and blue similarly
there are many other colors of eyes that
exist in nature so the eye color is the
character the eye color can vary among
the population of a particular species
on the other hand the trait will be
black or blue color of the eyes which is
exclusive for that particular individual
to take another example height is a
character while tall or short are the
traits hair color is a character while
black and blond are the traits the
passing of traits from one generation to
the other is called heredity and what
has been passed the next generation is
usually referred to as inheritance now
tell me one thing if this boy has
inherited the traits from his parents
why is he not the exact copy of either
of the parent I mean why does he look
slightly different from both the answer
lies in the single term called variation
isn't the term self-explanatory as the
name says it means differences so
variations are the differences that make
one organism different from its parents
as in the case the boy has inherited a
few traits from his mum and a few from
his dad but he is different from both
does there are many variations in him
these basics in genetics are known to us
now but ever wondered who laid the
foundations of this interesting subject
who were the pioneers in genetics that
helped us crack the
of life let's have a glance at the
history of genetics in the upcoming part
this image of evolution is not new to us
but ever wondered how species evolved
how are a few factors eliminated and a
few carried forward well the answers are
obtained when we combine evolutionary
studies with genetics many scientists
have been working on genetics since ages
but there was this one legendary figure
who could answer why a green pea plant
gave rise to another similar green pea
plant let's get back in time to
understand how the foundation of
genetics were laid genetic studies were
carried out since the classical era
wherein scientists like aristotle and
hippocrates have put forth a few
theories regarding how parental
characters are passed to the next
generation however a breakthrough was
achieved when an Augustinian friar
carried out remarkable experiments using
garden pea plants and laid the
foundations of modern day genetics it
was around the 19th century that Gregor
Johann Mendel now known as the father of
genetics performed the experiments that
led him to this path Mendel while
working in a garden wondered why the
green pea plants with one particular
trait gave rise to plants with the same
trait for example plants with purple
flowers gave rise to plants with purple
flowers only so why is this so and why
do white color flower plants give plants
with white color flowers only and what
will happen if these two varieties are
crossed with all these queries in mind
Mendel decided to carry out a few
experiments that would help him find out
all the answers but where did he think
all these experiments would take him how
did he think of beginning with the
procedures and what were the list of
requirements he gathered what could have
been the possible conclusions
let's try answering all these questions
one by one to begin with let's
understand why did Gregor Mendel chew
spice mSATA them commonly known as the
green pea plant Mendel knew that for his
experiments he would require a plant
which is perennial and not annual in
literal terms perennial means something
that can last for a long time here it
meant the plant that can grow and
reproduce in a recurring fashion
secondly the plant should have a small
life cycle it should be able to grow
quickly also Mendel wanted a plant that
would not require too many exclusive
conditions to grow minimal requirements
should suffice the growth of the plant
most importantly to understand the
results of crossing different varieties
better Mendel required contrasting
traits in the plants that means one
character should have two contrasting
traits for example the flower color in
green peas is purple and in some it's
white purple and white are the
contrasting traits that can help in the
study so which were the contrasting
characters that Mendel found in the
green pea plants there were seven pairs
of contrasting characters in total
chosen by Mendel in the plant and here
they are the first character Mendel
chose was height of the plant the
contrasting traits were tall and dwarf
plants second character in the list was
the color of the flower the contrasting
traits were purple colored flowers and
white colored flowers and the third
character on the list was position of
the flower that could be axial or
terminal in simple words axial means the
flowers shoot off from the middle of the
stem and terminal means the flower is
situated at the top of the plant stem
the next character chosen was shape of
the seed we note that green peas have
two types of seeds one type is round and
smooth while the other type is rough or
wrinkled with scales this was the next
pair of contrasting traits after the
seed shape
we have the character of seed color the
contrasting traits in this are the green
and yellow colors of the seeds similar
to the seed color the next character was
pod color a pod is nothing but a case
that holds the plant seeds here the two
contrasting traits were green colored
and yellow colored pods and the last
pair of contrasting character was that
of port shape green pea pods can either
be inflated or constricted both these
traits are contrasting with these seven
pairs of contrasting characters Mendel
began his experiments little did he know
that he was building the foundation of
modern genetics let's have a look at
what his experiments were and the
conclusions he derived from them in the
next part we have taken a look at the
seven pairs of contrasting characters
chosen by Gregor Mendel for his
experiments on the green pea plant so
here's the table that gives us an idea
of what the contrasting characters and
their respective traits were now can you
guess how mental thought of this
experiment how was it exactly planned by
Mendel what was his aim well Mendel
thought of beginning with trying to
understand what happens on crossing the
plants with contrasting traits Mendel
just like others knew that a plant with
purple flowers gives us another plant
with purple flowers only and it's the
same case with a plant that has white
colored flowers now Mendel was curious
to know what will happen if a purple
flowered plant is crossed with the white
flowered variety ideally the result has
to be flowers with intermediate colors
but was that actually what Mendel got
let's have a look at the results in
detail but before that do you know how
Crossing is carried out
well the male and the female plants are
selected first now the pea plant being
bisexual
both male and female reproductive parts
in the same plant so we can choose the
purple flower to be male and the white
flower to be female or vice versa now
the female flower on the respective
plant is emasculated first so do you
know what emasculation is as the name
suggests masculine refers to male so
here emasculation refers to the removal
of male reproductive parts let's take
these two flowers to understand the
crossing process in detail now the
anther of this flower will be removed
removal of anthers makes sure that the
flower will not get self pollinated now
this exclusive female flower is dusted
with the pollen grains from this male
flower which ensures pollination and the
successful fertilization will be ensured
when the plant develops flowers this is
how Crossing is carried out now let's
get back to Mendel's experiments Mendel
crossed a plant with purple flowers and
a plant with white flowers he expected
results in which the plants obtained
will be intermediate between purple and
white but to his astonishment he
obtained all the plants in the progeny
to be purple colored unexpected right
and this doesn't stop here on crossing
the purple colored flowers from this
progeny with each other he got another
set of astonishing results if purple
flowered plants are crossed amongst each
other we should obtain which variety we
would get all plants with purple colored
flowers is what most of us would think
but to his astonishment Mendel obtained
a few plants with white colored flowers
as well so on an average he obtained 75%
plants with purple flowers and 25%
plants with white flowers how could this
be possible now let's try and understand
these results in the next part
[Music]